so we've got some rather exciting news
for you here at trigonometry tells ya
guys there is no censorship on YouTube
we just wanted to confirm that as you
might remember we had a comedian on a
few weeks ago to talk about this very
fact and he was arguing with us and
saying there is no censorship YouTube is
not you know pressing any free thought
free thinking and guess what guys
even that episode has now been
demonetised to be fair he was chatting
[ __ ] clearly say see that so fair play
to YouTube we're in agreement so that's
where we are guys we've had a bunch of
videos that have been demonetized
YouTube have obviously got this new
algorithm now since the whole steven
crowder thing and that is where we are
we are losing money every time we put an
episode out most of them get D monetized
straight way and by the time even if
they do get romana ties most of the
views have already happened in the first
24 to 48 hours so look this is where we
are we've been doing the show for a year
we've never really asked people for
support we've had a patreon we've had a
paypal we've kind of said that it's
there if you want to support the show
but at the point we are now is
essentially we cannot keep doing the
show unless we have the money coming in
which YouTube are now gradually taken
away from us so if you believe in what
we're doing if you think that it's
important this is the time that we need
your help we have the patron we have the
the PayPal link below we have subscribe
star as well if you believe in what
we're doing if you want to support us
they're there for you please do do do
that we've had a lot of people on
patreon you can get a bunch of rewards
you can get a trigonometry mug you can
get access to previews of the episodes
etc please do support us because it will
allow us to keep the show going I have
been wearing the same t-shirt for a
month now so we need your money I can
tell you guys I have to sit next to him
every time so that's it guys if you can
support us please do and we will
hopefully see you in a week from now
with another episode of course we also
have a bid shoot account as well because
we are worried that we might get chased
off YouTube in the long run great news
guys thanks for being with us see you
soon